quand j'étais un garçon, je devais choisir le chemin ou le
destin choisirait pour
moi J'ai blessé des gens et je vais
souffrir
encore plus Je demande pardon pour ce que je
m'apprête à faire Les
guerres de gangs de sauvages Cette
ville
s'effondre
Puissions-nous  sommes les seuls à qui nous pouvons
[Musique]
faire confiance, la trahison n'est pas quelque chose que
je peux
[Applaudissements]
ne rien pardonner cela m'apporte de
la joie tu as causé ça sur
toi-même, ça me fait mal
Je dois
te tuer encore. Studios Echo tous les épisodes en
streaming le 9 janvier réglez votre
Le profil Disney Plus sur TV MA pour diffuser la
discrétion du téléspectateur est
conseillé
Amaya Je te vois J'ai toujours des
tigres qui bougent en silence pour attraper
leur
proie tu es un tigre
Maya qu'as-tu fait Marvel Studios
Echo de tous les épisodes en streaming le 9 janvier